so what are our goals today we want to
help you make a great first impression
in your phone and video recorded
interviews and to do this we're going to
talk through some tips we're gonna work
through it then we're going to have a
little practice as if it was a phone
interview and you can start thinking
about this in the back of your mind
we're gonna I'm gonna have some time
I'll be talking for a little while
longer but start thinking at a project
that you might want to talk about in a
first interview and I want you to think
about describing that project to a
non-technical interviewer because a lot
of times that first interview the phone
interview or especially video recorded
interview who knows might see it but
it's often going to be going through a
non-technical person an HR someone who's
not an hiring manager so we want to make
sure that you feel confident describing
one of your projects to a non-technical
interviewer so be thinking about which
project you might want to talk about
you'll have about twenty minutes until
you have to do it
nothing like pressure at the last second
so what's our agenda I'm gonna talk for
about the next 15 or 20 minutes about
tips and techniques for phone and video
recorded interviews then we're gonna
have a breakout session for about 15
minutes and we're QA that should not say
two minutes that should say about 20
minutes oh sorry about that I will I
promise you'll have more than two
minutes for questions
so let's think about this why should we
spend time preparing for an initial
screening I work with so many people who
have sudden panics because they have an
interview coming and they haven't
prepared and they think well it's just
the phone interview it's just that first
screening how how important can that be
so let's think about why is it that
important why is it important for us to
prepare that
you
if we think about that it's all about
first impressions we all know that first
saying up at the top you never get a
second chance to make a first impression
and that's what we really need to work
on and that next quote I think is very
typical 33% I would guess even higher of
interviewers claim to make a yes or no
decision in 90 seconds so you think
about that they have an impression of
you all you really pretty much had time
to say is hello and maybe a little bit
about yourself and they've already
started
subconsciously unconscious bias whatever
it is made a decision whether they think
you're the right person to go to the
next round so really really important to
get that first impression right in this
bottom one I've talked to a few
recruiters who've told me the same thing
that they have more rejections happening
after the phone interview stage than
ever before and I think that's a really
interesting thing to think about and
there's a couple reasons where or people
think it might be happening one there's
a lot of may be discrepancies about what
people think the applicant Trek tracking
systems are getting them for candidates
what that AI screening all that Unai we
got to improve this because they're
finding that all that keyword search is
not always necessarily getting them the
right candidates in the first round but
another reason people think phone
interviews these rejections are
happening is because people don't have
the phone skills that they used to
people aren't talking on the phone as
often as they used to
people aren't needing to use their voice
and and think about their inflection and
getting their point across in a stronger
way because they've been able to text or
email or if you are in person use those
different skills so really really
important to have strong vocal skills
and we're going to talk about some of
those but for
get some of your input what do you think
you can do to make a great first
impression if your friend was going into
an interview right now and they said
what should I do to make a good first
impression what are you gonna tell them
I'm going to Papa
see my chatbox ooh Bret is saying the
presentation isn't shared and I couldn't
see the chat box so feel free to unmute
yourself and speak up if we've got a
technical problem let me share that
sorry everyone I was under the
impression the it was all happening so
let me get the question up here post
your answers in the chat box how can I
make a great first impression
imagine you are talking to a friend
right now
who is
going into an interview and you need to
tell them what should they do to make a
great first impression
all right confidently speak about
yourself very good a warm and polite
greeting very good what else give me
some thoughts everyone your best friend
is going into an interview what are you
gonna tell them great Brett be on time
very good what else what are you gonna
tell your best buddy give him some good
advice they're going in right now what
else can they do
smile when you speak even on the phone
really good when I wanna that's
absolutely true people can hear your
smile confidence and no hmm so while
speaking very good no lumps and hoons
excellent really confident voice
sumitra says don't hesitate to say I
don't know if you don't good hopefully
in the first 90 seconds you know
everything you need to say because
that's really where you have the power
to step in and
we can get into a little more about the
what you don't know know exactly the
message you want to convey that's really
good Sylvia when we think about needing
to know your own message for every
interview you need to go in and think
what do I want that person this company
to know about me
because it could be a little different
for each job each company you talk to
might be a little bit different
be yourself and don't exaggerate really
good just be yourself be authentic these
are all great great things so I'm going
to pop up my next slide to talk a little
bit so some of the ideas we're going to
talk through some of these
so eye contact first thing to do to
build trust I'm going to stop it start
at the top of the screen up there really
iContact making that connection with
someone your attire how you're dressed
we'll get into a little bit more about
phone and video interviews but always
dress for the interview even if you know
you're just going to be you know sitting
in your home office or you're gonna be
stepping out of a meeting dress for the
interview you're gonna it's going to
help bring that confidence level up
smile we said that earlier just give
that smile off give that positive energy
and you get it back from that person as
well and yes if you've seen my tips this
weekend a student Hubbert on slack
people can hear your smile it actually
when we smile our brain sends endorphins
and those of you might have a medical
background know better than than I do
but it really helps spread the
endorphins that positive energy and
someone smiles back at you one of the
questions that just came up do we need
to look into the camera into the screen
while having a Skype interview and we're
gonna get that and definitely look into
your camera the next up there on the
screen confidence we want to project
that confidence body language think
about the body language you're using
obviously if it's a phone interview
they're not gonna see it but again when
you think about everything that can make
you appear and feel confident its
posture it's eye contact it's open hands
use all of that when you're on the phone
and in these video recorded interviews
we're going to talk about or anytime
you're on just like I am right now I
don't want to be if I was just sitting
like this or like this
it was so disinterested like it would or
maybe I was just like sitting kind of
like angry looking you want to have open
hands show that open body language sit
up tall really show that confidence that
posture and to show you're interested
and you're serious and you're engaged
have a positive tone even when they're
asking a question like have you had a
challenge has there been an issue you
have a colleague you've struggled with
always always explain your answer and
but in a way that you can show the
positive results the outcomes the great
things that happen at the end and use
that strong voice practice with your
inflection especially this can be a
struggle if you're interviewing in a
language that is different than your
native language it can be a little
harder to to know when and how to use
that inflection or it's just because
you're thinking about what you want to
say so much it's harder to get that
inflection out so think about as you
practice maybe some of the things you
can really emphasize in word you can
really put out there to show that
stronger voice and that inflection in
your voice and of course using just
professional body language professional
speaking language grammar everything to
just come across really polished and and
confident
so those are some of all the things we
can talk about when making great first
impressions and this obviously relates
to in-person interviews phones whatever
it is
so what we're gonna go through today
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
phone and video recorded interview
etiquette we'll learn some tips and
techniques besides those first
impressions we just talked about
then we're gonna get have a little
practice we're gonna go into breakout
rooms and that's where you're gonna
describe your project to a non-technical
person and if you struggle to think
about that some people say think about
if you were describing it to your
seven-year-old niece or child or maybe
you were describing it to your
grandmother smart people just not
educated in the technical areas of what
you do so think about describing it to
someone you know has no technical
background that's where you're lucky
that Brett and I are on because we'll be
popping in and out of the rooms and
we'll be giving you some feedback can I
understand it can Brett understand it
can we do we understand what you're
trying to articulate again that's just a
practice so that we could have some time
with the workshop today
so phone interview basics typically it's
a first round screening it can last
anywhere from 15 minutes to 30 minutes
and it really depends like sometimes
people get worried if it's cut really
short they feel like it just didn't go
well sometimes they're just asking a
couple of really quick questions and
they got enough to know they want to
bring you back but the longer you can
keep them on and keep it interested in
and have like a little bit longer is
always better
typically these will be arranged via
email with a very specific time and a
specific person who is going to call you
so you shouldn't just have like a random
call and they say oh can I interview you
right now it should be something that's
planned in advance
and again it's often with a
non-technical person I'm gonna pop over
to the questions real quick the question
is could you elaborate on a strong voice
so if you imagine that let's just say
I'm in a video interview right now and I
was talking with this I was describing
my project and I thought that this would
be what you want to hear and this would
sound really exciting you can tell
that's not a strong voice right I'm not
projecting I'm not showing my enthusiasm
my energy I want to talk about my
project and this amazing amazing digital
marketing campaign that I just did and
the results that I had like show that
energy of course you still want to be
yourself if you're not a very
extroverted loud person but you don't
have to be something you're not but just
up tall with it with some power to your
voice that you're projecting and you're
getting your point across in a competent
manner
a little bit more about phone interviews
make sure you're ready early and you're
in a quiet environment you want to make
sure there's not a lot of background
noise use your earbuds it blocks out a
lot of other noise it helps you hear
them clear and you don't have as much
extra noise happening so and then always
answer the phone ready to speak to
someone so if my phone if I had an
interview at 3 o'clock and the phone
rang right now and I just said hey
what's up or or hi hello they it makes
for an awkward buzz this is this Angela
I'm calling for soda so always get in
habit of answering your phone hello this
is Angela speaking her or however in
your country is for coming but always
say your name so they're clear they got
the person and it just starts that whole
conversation off without uncertainty and
of course make sure your phone is fully
charged there's nothing worse than
suddenly realizing you're having a phone
interview and you've got the little
battery read up there video recorded
interviews so if
haven't had one of these yet sometimes
spark higher and higher view the Yui are
two common ones this is where a lot of
times it it can be a very atom automated
process in terms of you might apply to a
company and you immediately within an
hour five minutes get an invitation that
says would you like to submit a video
interviews would you like to participate
in our video interview submission and so
good and bad one is that you're getting
into their database that is that if
companies are always sending it
sometimes you don't know if anyone's
ever really watching that and it's just
going into a database that could be
searched someday but either way
definitely do it get the experience get
your name in there they it does often
also result in another round so get what
usually happens is you've applied online
you get the email invitation and it will
give you a time window that you need to
submit so it might say you have five
working days or you have 48 hours
whatever it is you do it at your
convenience but it does have a very
specific time window so make sure that
you read those emails closely to see
when the deadline is typically it's
through a third party like I mentioned
hirevue or spark hire two big ones they
can be around 20 to 40 minutes in
duration and typically they are timed
questions so a question I'll pop up on
the screen sometimes it's even a video
of someone asking you a question it's a
recorded video that they say hi please
now introduce yourself and tell us a
little bit about your education
background whatever they might say
they'll give you the question then they
typically will give you a minute or two
to to read that question and prepare and
think about your answer then you hit a
record button when you're ready and you
have it that would be timed as well it's
usually between I've seen two to four
minutes to provide an answer when you're
done answering you hit the button to
turn it off and it stops recording if
you're talking and you're out of time it
will just shut you off I always tell
people not to panic if you see that
start to happen
just keep talking as if that wasn't
gonna happen try not to be talking go oh
oh no I'd only have three seconds I have
to stop you know anything like that so
sometimes it gives you only one chance
so you answer that question you recorded
it it's done some companies are a little
nicer and they let you have multiple
chances or a couple chances to erase and
try again so they're a little bit
stressful I've done them myself but you
know and again looking at the camera
we'll get into that a little bit more
later but they're all a little bit
different so the key thing is to read
the instructions understand sometimes
they'll have a practice question I
always recommend doing that so you kind
of understand how the technology works
and you feel a little more comfortable
that way a few more things again read
the instructions test your tech make
sure your Internet's good your cameras
working your microphones working all of
that look at your camera make sure your
eye level a lot of laptops I've noticed
just recently some people had Dell
laptops and their cameras at the very
bottom of their screen which is hard
because then your are looking down and
you need to raise it up so that your eye
level and you just people feel that
connection with you you're looking at
the camera they can see your eyes make
sure you have a clean and simple
background no dirty laundry literally
I've seen people with things hanging all
over behind them try to find this plane
of a background as you can and have some
good lighting the space I use now in my
office I've got a light that shines from
back behind my screen which which helps
a lot if you're in a dark space try to
get a light behind your computer shining
at you a bit professional tire again be
ready they're gonna people are gonna be
watching this practice even if you don't
want to log into their system yeah you
can go on to higher view and spark
higher you can look at they have YouTube
videos you can watch they have practice
thing activities on their site that you
can do
professional attire you know obviously
if it's if it's a very casual company
and you don't feel like a suit is the
right thing at least maybe a collared
shirt or you know just look look like
you're going to work in impressing
people in an interview
it's always better to be overdressed
than underdressed
so remember set the stage be ready early
whether that's the phone interview or a
video interview use your earbuds dress
for an interview have a confident
posture know your pitch if you're not
sure what your pitch is and you're
listening to this now we've done
webinars on creating your pitch before
and we've done a lot of practice with
those so go back and watch some of those
find time to practice your pitch is
super important and just practice
practice practice
again how do you practice know your
pitch practice your pitch research the
company and possible questions so glass
door and CrunchBase are two really great
places to look for previous interview
questions
most of these first round type
interviews are not super technical they
are typically more of an introduction
it's like just getting to know you a
little bit some might go slightly
technical it all varies by the company
that's why it's good to do your research
looking at Glassdoor and CrunchBase both
can help and just practice those typical
first round interview questions and I'm
gonna give you a list of those this is a
list really that I've kind of come up
with that I find people are asked I keep
a little database after my clients have
interviews to to see if there's new
trending questions out there but pretty
much the first round tell me about you
why are you interested why do you want
to leave your old job why do you think
you'd be a good fit what's your biggest
strength what's your biggest weakness
feel free to take a screenshot of this
not real complicated questions and then
oftentimes they want you to talk about a
recent project maybe a recent project
you're proud of a recent project that
was a big challenge to you whatever it
is hopefully by now we're getting close
to practice time that you have all come
up with your